this is the smallest Android smartphone
I've ever used and it's called the uni
Hertz jelly 2E a mini Android 12
smartphone now it has a three inch
screen size and it only weighs 110 grams
and not only that it only costs 169 US
Dollars and as weird as it might sound
I'm actually quite impressed with it but
why you might be asking gee Zaki why
bother when you've got an iPhone 14 pro
as a daily driver why can't you just use
it like a regular smartphone like that
and you will be right but the
distractions of a smartphone don't come
from the phone itself but how you set it
up and to put it simply with a million
apps on my iPhone the distraction is
just too overwhelming it simply doesn't
bolt well for productivity and I felt
that that was an actual problem I was
checking my phone first thing in the
morning and last at night just bombarded
with new messages emails to-do's and
other stimuli that often makes me
stressed and anxious giving me no time
and space to start my day calmly I just
felt hijacked and it didn't stop there
by allowing myself to do so I set the
tone for a distracted day and I felt my
ability to focus got heavily decreased
and stayed glued to my phone all day so
I did decided to go caught turkey for a
week with some smartphone detoxing if
you will with the uni Hertz jelly to e
and for the most part I actually enjoyed
the experience now of course there are
just a few things on this phone that I
wish it had and at least some that's
worth paying a little more to get better
Hardware but again this is a budget
phone so I have to dial back on my
expectations a little bit with that said
unit had still did a good job with the
Jelly 2E and here's why but before we
get into it this channel is supported by
Brands to help us improve our content
and keeps us going so stay around for
this sponsor message here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this makes a
format function helps the Titan Evo 2020
to deliver the best seating experience
like like no other for more information
check out secretlab.co so let's start
off with what you get in the box with
smartphones this affordable and this
Niche you'd expect it to be a complete
package that includes a screen protector
a USBC charging cable and a silicone
case inside unfortunately uni Hertz did
not provide a charging adapter here for
whatever reason but that's a pretty
quick fix if you already have an
existing charger lying around now one
nice thing about it is that it comes
with this cool little lanyard to tie the
bottom of your silicone case you know
just just in case you have this uh
battery fingers and a product dropping
the phone which is pretty cool now
getting right down to the aesthetic and
build quality just to give you an idea
of how small the phone is okay this is
the size compared to my 6.1 inch iPhone
14 pro it really is that small and we
are looking at a dimension of 4.8 CM by
9.3 CM by 1.6 CM with its weight again
at 110 grams so it's a really compact
phone however you do get a thicker Edge
you know it's as if you're kind of
fooling the the iPhone oh man I wish
iPhone made affordables that'd be great
anyway honestly I can't afford that
because if you think with a phone that
small you need some of that thickness to
a little wrap around your hand and it's
also easy to fill in the pocket I just
love it curvy Edge which provides a nice
grip wall still being great at 100 use
that that didn't come out right anyway
popping on the silicone case adds a
little bit more thickness and provides
more protection against you know
scratches and drops and to be frank with
you it's very reminiscent of the Nokia
3310 or the w800i so you do get that
retro feel God I'm really trying my age
now I feel old it's really Hardy it's
dense and it seems to be made out of
very hard plastic
and I'm pretty sure the j2e can sustain
some accidental knocks it drops as well
not they really want to but you can you
also have knickknacks and buttons here
with the volume buttons being on the
left side and on the right side you have
the power button and this rip
customizable shortcut button by default
holding the shortcut button will
activate the flashlight look at that and
double clicking it will you know take a
screenshot so there's that we also see a
dual SIM card tray on the right side
which bear in mind can hold a
combination of nano SIM and a Micro SD
card as well so you can easily expand
the onboard 64 gigabyte storage with a
Micro SD card of up to two terabytes
probably if you want to use two
terabytes on this phone it's nuts but
hey you do you we also have the USB
charging port which is
a little bit awkward especially if
you're right-handed it's not a big deal
because you got a 2000 milliamp hour
battery and it sounds small but with a
low power output on this phone it
actually charges relatively quickly and
lasts for for days more on that later
beneath the display you have the three
classic Android buttons with back home
and tasks which come in handy if you're
having trouble swiping up to get out of
air or switch between apps I mean the
display is really small so sometimes it
can get finicky and at the rear you have
a fingerprint scanner which is a nice
touch for added Security on top of the
facial recognition not for the phone now
for
the responsiveness of both it might take
a few tries with the fingerprint sensor
and the facial recognition you got to
have good light so I mean you got the
mix of facial recognition fingerprint
scanner and and pin if you're really
into keeping this little tiny phone very
safe then aside the jelly 2E has some
unique Hardware choices you've got 4G
connectivity Wireless AC otherwise known
as Wi-Fi 5 and an infrared Port now
what's surprising here is that there's
no NFC and 5G connectivity with the
former being pretty much the shortfall
because I use a lot of NFC contactless
payments so I feel it should be long on
every phone nowadays on top of that I
mean you don't really need the 5G it's
it's a small phone it processes a little
bit slower so you don't really need 5G
to watch 720p on YouTube now the most
interesting one is the infrared port and
I'm glad it's on this one because it's
just a quick way to turn on some home
appliances like the TV or the AC now you
do have to get a universal remote app
and I've been using this app called lean
remote it's got all the major brands and
it works with various devices like your
projector Blu-ray player AC TV and even
the Soundbars the app is simple and easy
to use and it's absolutely free so go
check it out now what you're getting
here on the screen is a really cute
three inch LCD display nothing fancy
here no amulet no OLED which isn't
really a bad thing you're getting a 480
by 854 pixel with a pixel density of 326
pixels per inch and for what is worth
the display is bright it's got
surprisingly good colors and the texts
are sharp now it can be a little bit
difficult to see details up close let's
say if you're just scrolling through
Instagram and you're trying to zoom in
since it's coming from a much smaller
display but that 326 PPI keeps all that
visuals sharp and I didn't feel as bad
as I thought reading through a whole
article on a small screen about say 35
centimeters away from my eyes with that
you also do get a decent viewing
experience when it comes to
entertainment so with YouTube videos
going up to 720p at 60 frames per second
and auto quality is what you expect from
a phone like this now you do have
downward facing speakers on the bottom
of the phone and they are not like
Boombastic but they're not enough to
listen dialogue and you can obviously
hear a ringtone in color places and
Union Hertz has kept it old school with
its 3 0.5 millimeter headphone jack but
you do get Bluetooth 5.2 if you like to
pair it with your wireless earbuds so
the typing experience here is a
it's very it's very mixed it's not a
phone that grants you Speedy thumbs okay
okay yeah I've got fat fingers to say
the least so it takes a while getting
used to in fact I find myself typing a
little slower but the touchscreen is
surprisingly accurate while using the
tip of my thumb it's something folks
need to be aware of and type in the
wrong letter is going to be like a
common hurdle so you know it is what it
is you know the shortcut or the
alternative here is to just simply use
voice messages
or you can even like utilize Google
Assistant to help you with speech to
text uh which you know also helped for
more urgent situations now if you think
about gaming
it
is
what is possible to a limited degree I
have to say that to a limited degree you
know don't expect heavy is really gaming
like Call of Duty mobile or mobile
Legends or like your fingers will be
blocking the majority of the screen so
if you like some sort of entertainment
then you know casual games like bubble
bubble or Angry Birds you know games
that are not so heavy on the graphics
they will do the trick camera wise we've
got a 16 megapixel rear camera and a 12
megapixel front camera uh overall image
quality well you know what you pay is
what you get so for the most part photo
quality is decent under good lighting
situations the colors look pretty
natural in most cases you also get up to
1080p video recording with the option of
electronic image stabilization to assist
in stabilizing the footage and I would
say that the cameras do a good job
and video calls will be one instance
where I use the cameras combined with
its decent call Quality as well now as
battery life goes as I mentioned before
you get 2 000 milliamp hour of battery
capacity with a long standby time of up
to more than three days so this includes
stock time of up to 3 hours and 20
minutes and LTE streaming of up to 5
hours and 30 minutes and music playback
of up to 9 hours and 30 minutes so
overall I've seen less screen time alone
due to the fact that having a phone this
small made it a great way to cut down on
my phone usage which also means for the
most part I've left this phone mostly on
standby lasting pretty much the whole
day and I know what you think it might
seem like torture to have a small
display all this while but it's a great
way to discipline oneself of course it
doesn't really get the fact that I still
work on bigger screens three of them
actually but with a smartphone something
events on the go you know it's still
good to cut back on that so after two
weeks will the universe jd2e continue to
be the daily driver for me as a creator
that's a hard no but doesn't mean that I
have not appreciated my time with it the
jelly 2E is great for those who want to
cut down on their phone usage for the
late night Doom scrolling and perhaps
help you be more present in your life so
the jelly Tui says what it does and it
does it well there's no doubler very fun
phone to use and I can see that the j2e
is going to be great as a secondary
phone another cool thing is that if you
want to get your kits on a mobile
without getting them lured into the
strange and private digital world where
screen time limiting apps just don't
work at all then this phone suits those
needs so that's the uni Hertz jelly 2E
in a nutshell I hope you guys find this
video helpful and I think that
minimalist phones are very unique and
there's a ton of them out there so if
you like me to review more of these
phones do let me know in the comments
down below and if you like this video
then check out our gaming experience
with the RG phone 7.